in diesem match du musst im hintergrund
ein video von babys beauty palace
aufmachen ohne
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen 20
gewinner mit redner zettel gesagt genau
und du kannst mit dabei wir spielen
heute wieder eine runde ja halte ich für
einen moment dass du mit spiel würde ist
weil er so ein typ mit dem konkurs der
ähnlichen skin war und zwar luca hat
wieder heute die möglichkeit im rahmen
einer luca sagt challenge dreimal
während dieser runde zwei wie games auf
sg vier mir etwas auf zu tragen was ich
machen muss und zwar sofort oder halten
dann wenn er mir sagt so und das geht
gut los also die runde läuft schon ich
habe ein paar kisten gelötet und ja ein
bisschen recht schon anfangen
du hast hast du immer nur drei wünsche
sie mit ihm mit dem was ich habe die
letzten mal gesagt du sollst auf zehn
erhöhen
du hast jetzt hat sich auch noch
beschwert nicht mal werden 20 oder 30
jahren vielleicht machst du sonst mal so
bei der video 1000 alles klar dass ich
mir etwas wünschen darf das jetzt nicht
klar geht dann gehe ich halt falsch
gedacht
user lässt denn ich wusste dass ich
wusste es ich habe es eine millisekunde
bevor es passiert ist selbst gesagt ach
so bitter diese zellen spielen
ich geb dir mal kurz bei infos ich habe
jetzt drei einer brüstung punkte
ich habe schwert und ich habe zwei
gegner die sich irgendwie nicht
gegenseitig angreifen werde ich von
einem verfolgte kurzen update
nein gerade liegt ja die würde man was
machen wie sehr wir geben dir fir hien
als letztes mal
von krise also oder oben ist eine alte
da zog mich nicht okay also hier oben
ist einer der schlechtesten und ich
glaube den kann ich holen
368 vor christus erwägte jesus von
nazareth den licht der welt
facebook seite
ich schickte jetzt das bild im blended
ist eine folge damit die nicht denken
noch nicht komplett fit ist oder wie wir
nach eigentliche sprüche mit wilders ist
mit bildern ok darauf ein
doch ich warte er ist tatsächlich recht
schwierig vertauscht eine bayern hände
für zwei minuten alles klar für zwei
minuten natürlich nicht ich doch die
zeit junge was das geht gar nicht meine
mikros dazwischen warten
ok junge
ich kann mich mal weg gelaufen
30 sekunden okay noch 40 sekunden
leider schafft er's ich hoffe einfach
nur dass niemand mich jetzt angreift
kann ich nicht mal umdrehen
nein bist du bescheuert nein in
minecraft meine ich warte ich mache euch
mal die webcam unter dass ihr das seht
sieht man das so spiele ich jetzt gerade
das ja witzig wie das aussieht muss alle
details der 36
noch 15 sekunden noch 15 sekunden okay
soweit habe ich alles überlebt es läuft
es läuft will ich sagen okay geht läuft
jetzt auch im film abgelaufen hat sich
dafür zurück so ok oh ja die
abgelaufenen gibt mir mehr von diesem
sound wollte ich kann diese runde
einfach überhaupt nicht spielen
probiere das mal über kreuz kann man
nicht spielen es ist kein scherz
das geht nicht du kannst kriegs
überkreuzen nichts gebacken oder ist
eine maxi für pixel prinz heißt der
ich habe nicht so geiles equipment ob
ich denn damit überraschend wegklatschen
kann versucht jetzt pixel prinz
anzugreifen
ich habe aber vier oder +4 noch 23
dementsprechend noch 3 er sieht mich
aber nicht den kann ich mir holen kann
ich mir holen dann kann ich mir holen
aber die frage ist wie komme ich auf
dieses dach da drüben jetzt ich sage ich
dazu zu rift patch gold apfel sehr schön
die hatte einiges erzählt dass du ihn
schlägst alter was was zu wohl davon
hält tapfer zu ich bin ich bei der sache
sei für eine minute komplett ruhig
stoppt die zeit jetzt 58 90 57 56 45 54
53 straßburg stimmte das klatschen
dritte woche verloren
jetzt wusste sterben fünf mal wieder
leute von dir
2000 jahre später danke danke danke
schön
okay das mal startet damit startet schon
und ich hab mir grad ein ok bringt sich
selbst um
von leon luca ist nicht verboten glaube
ich ja genau bestimmt stimmt dass ich
ganz vergessen das ist nämlich bei lukas
verboten dass wir ja also wir machen sie
zum zweiten mal damit ist es
gewissermaßen auch schon format okay ich
bin im deathmatch
ich habe mal ein schwert ich hab bogen
pfeile japanisch für dich schnapp dir
dein penny bord und fahrt zum gegner
ich habe gewartet doch ich habe beim
liefert okay leute
wir fahren jetzt ein gegner
alles klar wir können zum gegner
okay ich hatte der zufolge auch entfernt
die woche
das gibt's ja nicht wie wir die folge
kommt wahrscheinlich vor der zufolge
oder ja aber voll gesät ich hab auch
2011 noch eine eine penney jcp bord
erwartet schweigen und hände über kreuz
also eine sache hast du noch und nicht
das nicht sein dass mich umbringe
das verboten ja okay lass dich von
jemand anderem umbringen warum darf ich
wenigstens versucht mich zu wehren
zu dritt an in diesem match du musst im
hintergrund ein video von babys beauty
palace aufmachen ohne
es gibt es doch nicht alte junge habe
ich etwas gewonnene spülmaschine oder
mama ich hab die waschmaschine geworden
doch habe ich hast du das tier hatte
hallo loukas louka hat eine
waschmaschine gewonnen
bitte endlich leute eine frage warum
bitte in den kommentaren
wenn ihr irgendwo idee hat warum